j'ai besoin de professionnels parce que
je demande beaucoup et un amateur je
demande beaucoup parce qu'on a
l'habitude de demander un professionnel
mais je
il a besoin de donner beaucoup plus
qu'il n'en a l'air
un professionnel est quand même payé
pour ça et c'est son métier donc il
trouve pas ça a priori absurde enfin il
est temps quand même supposé faire ce
qu'on a je pense qu'on lui demande ce
qui m'intéresse dans les professions
mais j'aime bien un professionnel mais
quand ils ne sont pas trop devenu c'est
à dire oh c'est leur côté non
professionnels ce qui m'intéresse chez
belmondo c'est son côté c'est son côté
amateur par exemple et vous avez tous
les murs brigitte bardot les deux seuls
problèmes vraiment j'ai eu avec elle
c'était lui faire arriver à lui fait
remettre sa jupe en dessous du genou et
ça j'y suis absolument pas arriver alors
gelé la majeure partie du temps au viage
les midlands dans un peignoir il bien au
contraire les cadres et ami ami poitrine
parce que ça pas question n'a pas voulu
elle tenait à ces petites jupes heures
et puis le faire baisser ce que sa
choucroute prince a son truc immense
alors sans laïcité dit c'était difficile
et que j'avais
la jour je demandé c'était à capri et
puis lui dit écoutez là c'est pas si
longtemps que je suis président ben ali
alors et je vous dis aujourd'hui que
c'est comme pour les juges je ne mâche
au cros ji tiens j'y touche toi qui m'as
tu es nous brit-brit enfin ayez
confiance en moi ça
puis il faut quand même c'est trop grand
c'est trop bon ça on va baisser coup tu
m'as vu
est ce que si par hasard est ce que si
ça ça faut moins 15 centimètres votre
truc au dessus du franc est ce que sk si
je hais ce que si je marche 15 mètres
sur les mains enfin disons parce que si
je marche sur les masques chaque mètre
que je marche sur les masses cool
accepté de baisser d'un centimètre votre
coiffure
je n'accepte pas ce que c'est que vous
savez pas marcher sur les mines à noël
m'a dit oui alors devant la chérie je
fais ça
[Musique]
j'en ai fait un peu plus corps et bâle
en charge à la relève match cruz
[Musique]